on va penser avec gerald bonsoir soir
céline martin nous en parlait c'est en
coupant dans les dépenses que le
ministre des finances a réussi à trouver
ce surplus absolument et qui qui arrive
à des marges de manoeuvre en quelque
sorte vous savez en 2014-2015 l'exercice
qui s'est terminé le 31 mars dernier qui
est en surplus on a moins dépensé que
prévu un milliard de dollars de moins
que prévu et c'est vraiment ce contrôle
des dépenses qui permet au gouvernement
d'annoncer des surplus parce que les
revenus au cours des prochaines années
ne seront pas nécessairement au rendez
vous la croissance économique mondiale
et la croissance économique des pays
occidentaux et la croissance économique
du québec est modeste et sera modeste
2015 2016 on prévoit maintenant une
croissance du pib de 1 5% 2016-17 1,7
alors qu'on prévoyait 2 % de croissance
du produit intérieur brut malgré cette
faible croissance
le gouvernement va être capable de
dégager des surplus de 1,5 à 3,5
milliards au cours des cinq prochaines
années par année avant le versements au
fonds des générations c'est à peu près
de 13 milliards de dollars qui va
permettre au gouvernement d'aller
probablement de l'avant avec ses
intentions de baisser les impôts des
contribuables ce qui a beaucoup retenu
l'attention si ce réinvestissement en
éducation
mais le ministre l'état audi il n'y a
pas une coupe dans l'éducation
est ce que c'est bien le cas dans la
réalité dans la réalité quand on tient
compte de l'inflation ce n'est pas le
cas parce que la croissance des dépenses
qui est prévu cette année et la
croissance des dépenses qui prévu l'an
prochain se trouve sous la croissance de
l'inflation
donc en termes réels du point de vue
économique ce n'est pas une hausse des
dépenses en éducation même avec le
réinvestissement d'aujourd'hui c'est une
baisse des dépenses en éducation
mon parlons de l'ontario s'est
franchement plus difficile c'est une
province qui est moins endettée que le
québec mais qui a beaucoup plus de
difficultés à revenir en équilibre
budgétaire
aujourd'hui on a ajusté le déficit à 7
milliards 6 500 millions pour 2015 2016
après un déficit l'année d'avant de 10
milliards l'an prochain un autre déficit
pourquoi parce qu'on vend des actions
des douanes ça rapporte un peu plus
d'argent
un l'ontario mais on révise à la baisse
la prévision de croissance économique
l'ontario se trouve dans une situation
budgétaire beaucoup plus difficile que
le québec le québec qui a probablement
la situation budgétaire la plus enviable
en ce moment parmi les provinces au
canada mme yade si clair merci beaucoup
géraldine